foreign
what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here today would long
with
John is it are you sure how are you John
I'm good I'm good I'm concerned but good
G how are you concerned citizen of
Gotham City over here Gotham citizen
ladies and Gentlemen please go ahead
leave a like we're gonna talk about
um this Batman Beyond news here uh how
Warner Brothers canceled it now going
through it I was like okay maybe this is
a good thing actually because when I
first heard it I've had three reactions
first one was what
two uh actually you know maybe and then
oh come on that would have been awesome
so I'm gonna go through all that with
you so I think the third thing you don't
know about John that's the part I think
we did not get the update on so first
order of business what was being
reported first it came through Jeff
Snyder and then the rap confirmed it and
now The Hollywood Reporter reported on
it was that after the flash they were
planning a Batman Beyond movie starring
Michael Keaton with the script being
penned by I think her name is Christina
Hodson is that how you pronounce her
name yeah
Birds of Prey and Batgirl as well and
then when the James Gunn and Peter
saffron thing was announced or or like
when the meeting started happening they
were like stop stop writing stop stop
you and Patty Jenkins just stop everyone
stop it you're right no longer on the
clock and now here's the part of it
where I was like oh man that's a bummer
when I heard what they wanted to do with
it was like yeah they wanted to do like
old man Michael Keaton as Batman which
of course is like oh that's like the
dream right there if they got Tim Burton
to come back oh come on
could truly excite me with right now how
excited would that have been to finally
be like that's that's like the Dream
movie right there that would have been
so good because Batman Beyond is like it
takes place in the future eventually you
know Batman he's like he's too old then
Terry McGinnis comes into the phrase
trying to start beginning to take off
the Batman mantle you know how the story
goes in case you don't but that's how it
is but apparently they wanted it to be
set in the current DC Universe
so they didn't want to go into the
future what yeah that's the part of it
that I was like all right maybe it's a
good thing you didn't do this I think
like exactly way more than happy people
oh yeah so yeah I guess we would want
like the Robert Pattinson Batman to
exist in his own universe and then this
would be part of like the main one
something along those lines bottom line
it wasn't gonna be the futuristic world
that is so heavily associated with
Batman Beyond so that's what made me go
all right okay maybe maybe that's maybe
maybe it's a good thing still still give
it a shot Warner Brothers like down the
road with something but maybe do a woman
actually takes place in the future
because that's such an integral part to
it then this piece of news came out and
that's when I went
oh come on no no what is it this
actually excited me more than anything
else for some reason do they cast
chalamet to be Terry McGinnis yeah
that's what it was man
Finn Wolfson
right there yeah around the cusp yeah no
uh here's what it is
they wanted to bring back Catwoman
oh like like Michelle fight and I had to
have they they didn't confirm if it was
Michelle Pfeiffer but like which mother
Catwoman would it have been yeah
it would embrace the meme because like
the impression that I've been getting is
that they were gonna kind of Superman
Returns it in a way where they're gonna
ignore Batman Forever and Batman and
Robin and we're just gonna even though
those are technically the same Batman
from the Michael Keaton once yeah and
we're just going to pick it up after
Batman Returns and like discount forever
and Robin continue it after Batman
Returns and that Batman Returns movie
had that Cliffhanger that showed
Catwoman was still alive and then she
never came back into the fold and that
Romancing and her portrayal of Catwoman
is still my personal favorite yeah it
would have been so awesome to have them
reunite on screen and none of the Tim
Burton talk ever went down according to
any of these reports they didn't say if
it did or didn't but you know my little
headcan and it did or at least it may be
pondered it but if they had to come back
oh my God correct Michael Keaton and Kat
one and Michelle Pfeiffer is Catwoman
that just would have been such a
cathartic fulfillment yeah and you know
he still would have been cool to get
some type of like solo Batman movie in
some way but yeah the prospect of have a
fulfilling that storyline that did not
get to get fulfilled would have been
just so hype on my end so yeah that's
the experience of the Batman Beyond
canceled project for me it's funny I
mean I guess at that point I had a very
interesting reaction to to these pieces
of news assembled because yeah at first
I am like wait wait a minute so if you
put him in the present he's basically
just Nightwing but he's Batman but then
if Terry McGinnis comes in yeah yeah I
mean there have to be a Terry McGinnis
if they're gonna do a Batman Beyond yeah
absolutely well yeah it has to be but
but like setting it in the present day
just takes away a lot of yeah what makes
it unique but then thinking about you
know they're gonna basically just make
it the part three of the Tim Burton
Batman like as much as I feel like this
may be a little unfair to Batman Beyond
is a property in general it's not a bad
take for those characters at this age to
pass on that mantle which is pretty cool
and yeah about the only thing that Tim
Burton could truly like excite me with
at this moment because it is like
unfinished business and it makes me hope
and wonder if it's possible for James
Gunn and Peter saffron to maybe Embrace
some type of elseworld's wing of the DC
you going forward you know we live in a
day and age where it's now more and more
popular to a get the old band back
together and B skip a bunch of sequels
and make a direct sequel to something
that everybody loves you could do this
in an else worlds still like they're
gonna have to do that anyway like Joker
exists and is going to keep on going
Robert Patton says Batman existence is
going to have to keep on going like
those are I guess technically going to
be just their own little else worlds
like give a deal and build all the the
new iteration of Batman Beyond or
whatever you talked about wanting to do
that maybe that would be really cool
like and I think they would you just
like name drop them did you know that I
just thought like well
actually like they would be perfect for
that I'm pretty sure they spoke about
like wanting to do that at least dude
yep got it I'm hopeful for the future
but yeah it's a bummer to hear that this
is uh ostensibly canceled I mean if
Hollywood Reporter is putting it out it
must be legitimate but I'm like wow that
does seem like some dream you know sort
of DC's equivalent of a going back to
the Toby Maguire Spider-Man move yeah
yeah you know I would be curious to see
if they would Embrace doing something
like that that isn't Zack Snyder related
like that's also the the only thing that
could probably surpass people's
enthusiasm for the Snyder verse is like
oh man we're gonna complete the Burton
Batman that would have been
it would have been like me once I heard
Michelle Pfeiffer I was like I know I
know what oh hell here like it's ah like
that no especially in the recent years
like developing more and more
appreciation for Batman Returns
especially like this is my favorite one
favorite Batman of the four especially
my favorite one yeah please yeah make it
happen in some way because the thing
about Batman Beyond is it will work at
its strongest with a returning Batman
who is older that's why Michael Keaton
returning was perfect for this like it
could work with a brand new guy brand
new old guy playing Batman it would work
it just wouldn't hit the punch nowhere
near as strong if you it was just some
new guy a part of the appeal is a
returning Batman he's older now you know
dude 10 years down the line just do Ben
Affleck give it to Zack Snyder's Batman
Beyond oh yeah that would be great right
actually yeah
Snyder will be Sykes the audience will
be right yeah and it would work
excellent yeah
James Gunn uh you know I'm open for uh
suggestions that's not a bad idea at all
actually that works a lot yeah yeah it
could be a cool homecoming for everyone
all right guys well what do you think
about this uh Batman Beyond canceled
thingy leave your thoughts down below
you bummed what do you want what do you
want what do you want George Clooney to
do it come on all right subscribe leave
a like click that Bell last but not
least do a patreon
Lance door you're the bat you're the
Terry McGinnis of the channel because
you know you're strapping young lad
you're not as brooding as Batman I feel
like Terry McGinnis is kind of like
Spider-Man meets Batman in a sensibility
kind of way
more he's basically Nightwing but in the
future so so because he's in the Lance
you would fit in well in the future your
buff and sexy and handsome and and you
know Charming but you got a little bit
of that badass sight you know you work
with fire man so uh you know this
Christmas I just wish uh for you to get
a spandex suit
um you know like you know skin tight
late uh uh PVC or whatever that stuff is
that that gimps wear and and just you
know do a full Batman calendar and send
it to us uh we gotta get a new P.O box
what will we do send us that calendar
and we'll hang it in the background
right in the middle you can sell a bunch
you can be the new Markiplier too there
you go start your only fans buddy happy
holidays
feeling good
[Music]